hi thank you for coming to my talk I'm
sorry I couldn't join you in person as
it turns out it was probably the right
decision because as I understand the
conference has gone all remote so I'm
joining you from New York my name is Liz
Fong Jones and I am a principal
developer advocate at honeycomb dot IO
so today we're going to be talking about
how we can manage complexity in our
systems and how we can as DevOps
professionals make our systems more
humane to run so if you do have
questions as with the other talks during
today the Q&A is on slide Oh slide do
and then you'll put in the passcode
again key eight six zero and I think
it's the same as for the other talks you
if you're already signed in you can just
change the drop-down so why do I
emphasize the value of production
excellence and thinking about production
this is for a devops audience now I've
mechanic surprise but I think for kind
of more generalist audiences and for
when you're making the case to other
people in your teams we have to
emphasize that
well we write code rightly we're trying
to solve problems we're trying to
deliver business value to people and
that means that when we commit the code
into your trunk the journey has just
begun right that our job is not really
done until we've actually gotten the
code sustainably running in production
not just committed it into trunk ler
might deploy days or months or weeks or
weeks later and then potentially have to
be rolled back so the challenge that
we're facing as people who practice
DevOps is that production is becoming
increasingly complex and there are a
number of reasons for this uh it the
reason why we have DevOps and how we
came to have DevOps was that we've
recognized that the complexity was
better solved by putting people's heads
together by really encouraging
collaboration and encouraging people to
work together because otherwise we're
not going to be able to meet these
challenges of increasing scale and
increasing the rate of development the
whole reason why we try to pursue things
like my cursor
is because we want you empower teams to
release software separately on their own
Cadence's without strong hard
dependencies upon other teams because
otherwise you have a distributed and
wanton lift and that's no fun
but micro services do introduce their
own challenges because you no longer can
be aware of everything that's happening
in your stack and you can be no longer
aware of how things might break people
far above you and furthermore the more
data that we stream through our systems
the greater the workload the larger the
likelihood that at any moment in time
some subset of users is going to be
disproportionately impacted or that we
might unfortunately have a negative
impact upon someone's life because they
can't do something that they crucially
rely upon so we're adding complexity all
the time in order to try to solve these
challenges in particular we've done
things like add additional redundancy
systems add kubernetes add shorting rate
like and these are powerful techniques
for increasing reliability but they
unfortunately have the challenge of
creating a lot of operational
difficulties and therefore it's really
really difficult for us as developers
Knowles in 2020 if you understand or
came that complexity and bring it under
control so that we as teams can still
understand and develop it so I want to
ruminate for a few months about what the
meaning of uptime is the kind of things
used to be a lot simpler when I was a
baby sis admin um this was in 2004 I was
a systems administrator for a game
studio based in San Francisco in the
United States and we were a small studio
of twelve people and we had a single
product that single product was a
massively multiplayer online game where
massively multiplayer was defined as
supporting several thousand people
online at one time and in that
environment we had one game server and
one database server and if the game
server was up the game server was up for
everyone you know yes there were bugs
but from a reliability perspective up
was pretty simple to measure could a
client connect to the server so we
relied upon as a server up is
to be sir Rob that was it and yes I
still listening from the HSBC ads that
you see on airplane boarding gates
everywhere the other way that we can
think about things is thinking about
when there's actual user pain thinking
about when are people complaining to us
but ideally we'd like to be slightly
more proactive than getting to the point
of someone is calling the CEO of your
company because they want to cancel your
service right at that point it's too
late so how can we be more proactive
while at the same time recognizing that
our reality is that we no longer can
have a single server that's up we no
longer can have the notion of single
host monitoring guaranteeing that things
are working correctly and while we're
trying to maintain the baseline
reliability of our systems if their
challenge is that we are also expected
to improve the reliability of our
systems because even if our systems stay
frozen in place our user base is going
to grow over time and we're going to
need to do more things to scale out and
there are constant demands to add new
features as well so therefore it's this
constant balance of trying to get
everything done in the day they can
often feel very very overwhelming it
used to be that heroism could get us
through this that individual principle
engineers or lead engineers would work
themselves super super hard and/or just
think really hard and design a perfect
system but that doesn't really work
anymore um we no longer exist in an
environment we're dependent upon single
people is a good idea especially because
you know we have things like someone
could get stuck in quarantine halfway
across the globe and be unavailable so
we need different strategies we need to
think beyond what we did for the past
five or ten or fifteen or twenty years
that got us here and think about how do
we make things work for the next 15 or
20 years now you may have seen other
talks at this conference is talking
about specific pieces of technology and
I would caution you against thinking
that technology is going to magically
solve these problems that technology has
created what I frequently seen when
companies try to buy devops is that they
order the entire alphabet soup without
necessarily
recognising what their specific needs
are and what's going to actually solve
their problems for instance if someone
adopts continuous integration and
continuous delivery in order to ship
things faster but does not necessarily
guarantee that the things are going to
be correct a colorful saying is ship
ship faster means ship faster
there's also the element of thinking
about infrastructure as code so back in
the day I could bring down a single
server with one careless command with
infrastructure as code and terraform
congratulations I can now crash my
entire AWS environment with a single Mel
Mel form command
good idea right or what about kubernetes
everyone is talking about kubernetes
it's a hot thing should we do it well
maybe not maybe you don't need a
kubernetes maybe you don't need all of
that excess of complexity it depends
upon your means it depends upon do you
actually have a problem with scaling and
orchestrating your containers or if
you're not even on a containerized
environment then no you probably don't
need a kubernetes but I think the
largest concern that we have is often
that pager Duty is something that people
adopt the notion of if you feel the pain
you will fix it I do not think that
that's actually true I do not think that
it's actually true that if you write
enough pain to a development team but
they're going to magically realize what
they need to do to change here's what
happens when you put a team on calls
that is has never been on call before
and has a system that is extremely ill
tuned and offer them very little support
your alerts go off every single night at
2:00 3:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. 3:30 a.m. and
your engineers get grumpy because well
you can work out wake up at 3:30 a.m.
like 1 or 2 nights a week if you're
doing it every single night for a week
and doing your day job you're going to
eventually get frustrated enough that
you turn off the pagers but let's
suppose that you're motivating enough
that you do start looking at that alert
at 2:30 a.m. if the first thing that you
see is a wall of meaningless dashboards
that are not labeled that that are
drowning you in all this complexity and
information overload it's going to be
very very frustrating for you to
actually understand what's going on
inside of your system
there's the thing that pays you and a
million other things that are also
alerting and you have all these
dashboards with like 10 P different
pages of dashboards each of which has 10
different graphs on it which line
wiggled at the same time as that other
line right this is what we're using
human beings to do and it is extremely
destructive to their mental health and
while you're staring at these dashboards
and trying to spend 15 or 20 minutes
orienting yourself your customers are
waiting for you to fix the incident and
your incidents are taking longer and
longer to fix so finally it's 4 a.m. and
you pick up the phone and you call your
technical lead or maybe you are that
technical lead who gets woken up at 4
a.m. several times a week and you don't
get a break from the pager and like
everyone else because you are the lead
of the team and everyone goes to you for
help whether you're on call officially
or not and that leads to a problem where
you cannot take vacations or else a
session will go down that's no fun but
finally you fix the problem and it gets
to be 8 a.m. and you want to push a
longer-lasting fix and then you discover
that while the continuous integration
works the continuous delivery does not
that while you're testing each
individual piece in isolation and you're
not systematically integration testing
everything together that no amount of
staging environment testing is actually
resulting in having a predictable
cadence of release if you have a robot
if the robots knee is broken the robot
can't walk even if it each individual
bone is fine so this is a state that we
call operational overload where you have
insufficient time to do projects and
you're just constantly juggling all of
these all these fires all the time and
when you do find an hour to this free up
you don't necessarily have a plan you
don't necessarily know how you're going
to allocate your time in order to
sustain it get yourself to a place of
being sustainable so our teams are
really really struggling to hold on in
this situation and I think that it's
really unfortunate like I've been on
teams like this before and it's painful
it really sucks it makes you want to
quit your job most days
but I think that there is a better way
so let's focus first on kind of us as
human beings as people so I'm going to
breathe for a second because every time
I tell this story like every single time
no matter how many times I do it it
reminds me of those bad kinds as an ops
person and I really need to take a deep
breath so let's all take a deep breath
now that feels so much better doesn't it
right I think the thing that we're
missing is that we're missing that
people are the ones who operate and
develop our systems and therefore that
we need to refocus on thinking about
people first as our approach to DevOps
our tools are not magical right
continuous integration continuous
delivery do not make for a good DevOps
practice do not make for a humane
sustainable team no tool can help you do
something that you don't already know
how to do that you don't already feel
inclined organizationally to do tools
can nudge us tools can automate
workflows but tools cannot cannot
magically solve our culture problems so
instead we need to think about first
thinking about how we want to change or
closers and then after that we can
approach how we want to how we want to
use tools to facilitate that so we need
to invest in our people our culture and
our process that means that we really
need to focus on how do we encourage the
right practices to happen within our
within our companies so this is what I
call production excellence it's the art
of building sustainable systems that are
a proof that are appropriately reliable
scalable and build bring humans out it's
the idea of thinking about not just
reliability but also operability but
making sure that we do not feed human
being that we do not feed human blood to
the ativy gears of the computers so how
do we accomplish this you don't get
there through random acts of DevOps you
really have to plan we really have to
map out what are we going to do why and
how and we have to measure our signposts
along the way how can I communicate to
my stakeholders what they can look for
as signs of success what should they be
encouraging and are we willing to commit
the right thing in the long term and not
just the short term as I alluded to of
talking about executives we have to
involve everyone
we cannot just accomplish this with the
set of DevOps people and the engineers
and operators in the room we also have
to involve teams like customer support
sales finance and the business overall
and this requires a prerequisite of
having an element of psychological
safety we need to make sure that
everyone feels safe to ask questions and
to contribute what's relevant from their
point of view and we need to not feel
paralyzed by fear so how do we get
started with production excellence today
I'm going to be telling you the four key
elements of production out excellence
first of all we need to know when our
systems are too broken secondly we need
to be able to debug our systems when
they are too broken
third we need to collaborate across
teams in order to accomplish your goals
and then finally we need to close our
feedback loops we need to make sure that
we are addressing risks in our systems
and eliminating unnecessary complexity
of course there is the notion of
essential complexity of things that are
required that parts of our business
logic things that are required
absolutely to scale but not everything
needs to be curial on for the ride so we
have technical debt lurking in our
systems so we need to address that
that so why can I say a moment ago
measuring better systems as two broken
well I say that our systems are always
failing so I know that you all are
currently in Oslo word is probably very
gray and overcast and there is not
necessarily Brasco growing but sure in
the United States people have people
have lawns that in many parts of the US
are growing year round and they don't
necessarily expect all of Libra blades
of grass to be to be green right you
just expect is my grass roughly green
enough and if it is green enough then
you know it doesn't matter that one
single blade of grass has turned brown
so in our modern environment of
microservices there are always will be
networking failures there always will be
packets dropped right like that's fine
the question is does it fit for purpose
does it actually mean
customers needs that's what matters and
not Mike and focusing on making sure
that every part of our system is perfect
so let's measure what too broken is from
a business and customer standpoint this
is what I call the service level
indicator it's a concept that's borrowed
from site reliability engineering and
it's a mechanism for us to communicate
with each other both among each other as
engineering teams who have dependencies
upon each other as well as with our
stakeholders in terms of business needs
and and customers so they enable us to
talk about what reliable enough means
and as the fuel for this we need to
think about measuring our customer
experiencing measuring what are the
critical events or critical user
journeys that customers are trying to
accomplish and how can we measure them
how can we evaluate all the context
that's involved where's the customer
coming from already coming from Norway
are they coming from Denmark are they
coming from the UK which is now no
longer part of the EU what Bill idea are
they using what browser are they using
what was the request ID so I can trace
it through the system these are all
super super important qualities that we
need to have in order to understand not
just what is failing but what properties
are there's a failure to share in common
and we need to be able to tell which
events are good and which events are bad
from a customer satisfaction point of
view so one way of doing this is talking
to your product manager or talking to
your user experience researchers or
testing on yourself to try to understand
what makes for a good or bad user
experience we don't have to go it alone
there's ample research on this subject
already but if you're really not sure
you can just degrade your experience or
degrade your customers experience until
you notice that there's a problem for
instance adding latency to your systems
by doing chaos engineering discovering
that if things take longer than 800
milliseconds that feel sluggish maybe we
should make sure their site always loads
faster than 800 milliseconds so all of
this revolves around trying to figure
out what's a criterion what threshold
buckets events and be good and bad for
instance maybe it's that the HD code is
too honey
and that we serve in less than a hundred
milliseconds that might be our criterion
for measuring one load of our sight but
I also need to think about the
denominator how many total events did we
see the denominator is not a hundred
percent of your traffic the reason is
that we need to throw out botnet traffic
right the 403 is that you serve the
botnet should not count against your
service level objective similarly your
internal health checks while they are a
reflection of your own blackbox
monitoring they don't actually reflect
real customer experiences so we have to
focus primarily I'm thinking about the
customer first and then based off of
that we can compute our total
availability the number of good events
as measured by our threshold divided by
the number of eligible events and that
enables us to set a target service level
objective so a service level objective
is comprised of the service level
indicator as well as a window and a
target percentage why is the window
critical you probably can see why the
target percentage is critical but why is
the window matter
the answer is a short window is
meaningless if my site were a hundred
percent down yesterday but I came to you
and said I am 99.999% available today
you would scoff at me right you wouldn't
trust my service if I had a bad out six
months ago that probably doesn't
meaningfully impact your perception of
my service today so pick something
between one month to a year for your
window rather than then focusing on a
shorter when you're like a day or a week
so for instance one service of objective
might be that 99.9 percent of the vents
are good over the past 30 days where an
eligible event is defined as a hit to
the homepage and it is defined as good
if it was served in less than 100
milliseconds with HUV code 200 so why
did I pick 99.9% or 99.99% why did I not
pick a hundred percent the answer is
that when you pick a higher reliability
target than your you and your users
absolutely need you are sacrificing cost
and you're sacrificing develop
velocity you're paying far more for
excessive redundancy that your users
will never notice and you are also
sacrificing your development velocity in
order to slow down to try to achieve
that excessive degree of reliability we
all have applications that for instance
rely on people's internet connections
especially on mobile devices and
therefore if your mobile device connects
the Internet 99.9% or 99.8% of the time
why does it matter that your service at
you bet that's on the back end is
99.999% reliable you won't notice those
extra three nines of reliability so we
need to focus instead on barely keeping
our users happy meeting their
expectations and keeping their trust
without over delivering on reliability
and sacrificing on feature on other
features that they need reliability as
its core is a product feature just like
any other product feature so what can we
do that's action with our service level
objectives there are two things that we
can do first thing is that we can use s
ELO's to drive alerting we can use s loz
to decide what's an important problem
that's customer impacting and what's not
in order to measure this we need the
inverse of the service level objective
we need the error budget the amount of
allowed and availability if my objective
is 99.9% availability over three days
and it means that I'm allowed to have
point one percent of my queries over 30
days fail and I typically serve a
million requests per month for instance
then it means that I can have a thousand
requests per month fail so I can think
about how long at the current rate of
errors and I'm serving will it be until
I exhaust that budget allowed errors if
it's going to be hours then I need to
wake someone up to stop it before I
break the trust of my users and it's
going to be days it's acceptable for us
to wait until the next working day it's
not urgent and if there is no damage to
user trust then maybe it's not a problem
and we shouldn't alert on it at all we
don't need to alert any more on oh my
goodness the server is 19
percent CPU utilization 99% this is
horrifying or the surfers disc is ninety
point zero one percent fool the shock
the horror so this is a concrete example
of an actual others that we had several
months ago we had a two percent brownout
that lasted for twenty minutes at a time
four for about half that occurred
several times over the course of the day
traditional monitoring would not have
detected this because if you issued a
black box probe repeatedly it would be
unlikely that you would be among the two
percent of users affected in that twenty
minute window and even if so it would
only be a single blip not be multiple
blips that you typically would require
in order to alert someone
whereas measuring the actual experience
of our customers and measuring the
extent to which a customer was degraded
enable it us to determine that more than
99.99% are sorry that we were not able
to achieve our ninety-nine point nine
nine percent service level objectives
the second thing that you can do is make
data-driven business decisions
you can use your service level objective
to answer that tug of war do we need
more reliability or do we need more
product velocity if you have a service
level objective it enables you to use
that error budget if it's not being
utilized on other and predicted outages
to do experimentation we can do chaos
engineering experiments or feature
flagged rollouts where we know that the
blast radius is contained we know for
instance that if we roll out a feature
flag to two percent of users at worst we
will break those two percent of users
for five minutes before we roll back to
that feature flag that seems a lot more
acceptable than potentially rolling out
something to a hundred percent of users
and having it potentially blow up in our
faces
conversely we may need to invest in more
reliability if we've had a number of bad
outages and the service level objective
allows you to say we agreed as a
business that this was our target level
of reliability that would meet our
customers expectations if we're falling
short of that that's the first thing
that we need to address rather than
piling
more features in technical debt you
don't have to be perfect at having s
ellos what you aren't measuring is going
to hurt you if what you're measuring has
no correlation to user happiness you
really need to switch to any metric that
really will help you measure user
happiness so measure what you candidate
even if it is your Amazon load balancer
or or I or it's your your Google cloud
load balancer logs and then go from
there start entering your code even
further but you don't have to be perfect
at it and over time you need to iterate
to meet your users needs maybe their
expectations go up or go down this time
maybe your service of objective is
imperfectly measuring things if you have
outages that your service o objective is
not detecting then you need to improve
your service so objective
conversely if your service level
objective says things are wrong for
months and no one is complaining then
maybe your service level objective is
too aggressive so service level
objectives enable you to prioritize and
only alert on what matters but they're
only half of the picture why do I say
that well s ELO's stop you from waking
up for spurious reasons but when you do
have an outage you still need to be able
to figure out how we mitigate and how we
how how we prevent outage in the future
so our outages are never exactly
identical we need to begin with
curiosity to explore and understand how
is this outage different from anything
that's happened before how can I figure
out what's going on new outages need new
questions and failure modes can't be
predicted in advance if they could be
well it you'd be better off buying
lottery tickets predicting the numbers
then being a software engineer if you
had the power to foresee the future
similarly you know if you had the power
to foresee or theater you wouldn't write
that bug in the first place right so by
definition our failures are unexpected
they are unpredictable and therefore we
have to be able to debug new new cases
of errors in production not in staging
not in not in development although those
are important too but in production
your customers will not wait for you to
try to take it apart and reproduce it in
staging before he fixes in production
that could take days weeks your
customers can't afford to wait so
instead we have to think about how do we
actually empower people to investigate
things where we don't have full control
over the workload that's being sent we
have to avoid data silos we have to
avoid using disparate tooling we have to
avoid arguing over whose data is correct
funny story I know of teams that use a
data warehouse for analysis it takes two
days to get responses back from the data
warehouse that does not empower you to
debug things during an outage what I
found during my time as a site
reliability engineer was it I spent most
of my time when I was on call and
getting paged forming and testing
hypotheses using that growth mindset to
think about what are the Panjal things
that I might not have thought of how can
I verify them how can I understand
what's happening so I spend a lot of
time trying to figure out is this my
hypothesis might be is this component
broken for this user and then being able
to actually test and verify that this
requires being able to dive into our
data in order to ask you questions this
really really requires the ability to
try to understand how do we actually use
the telemetry and instrumentation in new
ways rather than just these same ways
that we've aggregated it before so all
of this is to say that our services must
be observable that our systems have to
be able to explain themselves to us and
answer our questions using the telemetry
that they're already exporting rather
than us having to push brand new code in
order to understand our services we have
to be able to treat our services as kind
of entities that can speak to us rather
than things that we had that we that we
have to push new copies of every time we
want to understand them better in order
to do this we need to be able to examine
each of the events that are flowing
through our system and as I said examine
all of those context fields that we that
we need to capture can we actually
explain the variance can we actually
understand is the cluster failures
disproportionately represented among one
particular set of users
or among one particular set of build IDs
or some combination of those two do we
have access to the relevant dimensions
and color tooling and our mentality
about clearing it allow us to discover
which dimensions are relevant and use
that to formulate a response to outages
and better yet do we really have to be
at 3 a.m. debugging things why can't we
automatically mitigate by rolling back
releases or draining for a data center
and debug our problems offline later
using the telemetry that was captured
during the incident
we shouldn't have to debug things live
in production if we can debug things
using the telemetry in production that
was captured later but observability is
not just for break fix observability can
benefit us throughout the entire
software development lifecycle from that
moment that we write code wouldn't it be
easier if we could debug our test
failures or write the instrumentation
that we will use in production at the
same time that we're writing the code in
development rather than bolting it on
afterwards we need to shift adding in
telemetry and adding in the capability
of observability need to shift that left
similarly we need to be able to predict
a balloon release you can write the most
perfect clone in the world but if you
have a build process that is taking
hours and hours or even days or weeks
and your changes are back together with
other changes that are likely to fail
that is much harder to practice
continuous integration delivery that if
you have visibility into your go
pipeline and could understand why is it
getting slow why is it getting flaky how
can we make it more reliable and at the
end of the day if what we build isn't
meeting user expectations and it's not
really worthwhile so can we actually use
observability to analyze what users are
doing and finally we really need to use
observability in order to keep control
over our systems to understand where our
risks where is the complexity how can we
onboard new people how can new people
understand and get visibility into the
architecture of the system thereby
managing our technical debt the other
thing is a observability is not just the
data we focus way too much on things
like logs Rice's and metrics logs races
and metrics are a way of
serializing the data for human
consumption but they're not actually the
whole picture of observability
observability is a capability of our
systems of our socio technical systems
comprising both the humans and the
computers can we as humans write the
necessary instrumentation in organ Amish
man er that feels natural to us so that
we can produce the relevant data and
store it cost efficiently and then
afterwards do we feel empowered to both
from a social perspective as well as
from a technical perspective clear the
data to answer the questions that we
have so service level objectives and
observability go together really well
because SLO is tell you when things are
too broken but observability helps you
debug and fix when that problem occurs
but you also need the element of
collaboration why is this as I said at
the start heroism is not sustainable
we all deserve the right to take a
vacation we also serve the right to
change jobs without damaging our teams
and without damaging our users
it just isn't sustainable anymore
anymore - to work for four years on end
without taking a break with people
bugging us all the time for information
that stays locked in your heads
debugging is not a solo activity you
have collaborations with the people who
are currently on call right like even if
your team practices on call where where
you share the on-call rotation you might
write code that goes out and breaks
weeks later when someone else is on call
you might have micro service
interactions where you have another team
service that is also broken the same
time as yours so you need to collaborate
with them so debugging is really not a
solo activity involves many many teams
and not just engineering teams it also
involves customer support your cloud
provider we all care about our customers
so all of us benefit from who acts and
excellence and contributing to it we
have to train our teams together we have
to practice chaos engineering we have to
practice game days and disaster drills
that way we understand in a safe
environment when nothing is immediately
on the line how things are going to
behave when there is an actual out
instant collaboration is deeply deeply
interpersonal service ownership does not
mean selflessness
it does not mean hoarding my service and
saying hands off my service right we
have to make people feel safe to
contribute to work together and to not
shift our organization charts we need to
lean on our teams it makes sense to have
teams that either practice follow the
Sun or even if they don't practice
follow the Sun divide up your on-call
responsibilities that you are not on
call for 24 hours each day for seven
days in a row that is not something that
is really sustainable to do in the long
term especially the hypogeum load and
there are people that have children
there are managers so you don't want to
get paid during their one-on-ones there
are people who observe religious
practices that don't enable that don't
allow them to do on calls during Friday
nights for instance in the European
Union there's the European Working Time
Directive right it says that you are not
allowed to work people to death that you
have to offer people time off after they
work beyond as prescribed number of
hours and that you can't make people
work work very very extended shifts
regardless of whether or not you
compensate them you cannot sleep you
can't be creative so make sure people
are getting the sleep that they need so
share your on-call rotations and divide
them up more evenly and cover for each
other and document your practices leave
yourself cookies not traps in the words
of my friends Hanyu reilly write down
the bright amount keep it organized you
don't have to write down everything that
becomes out-of-date quickly just write
down what is the service how is it used
why is it important how can I mitigate a
failure in the service how do I roll it
back how do I start debugging not every
single possible thing that has gone
wrong in the past so fix your hero
culture and really share that knowledge
out so that you can empower your teams
to do more and to do better so instead
of having someone in if someone comes to
you and says you know I'm sorry but I'm
having trouble understanding this don't
say can't believe you didn't know that
right like say I'm sorry that automation
wasn't clear let's work together to
document this right that feels so much
better in this part of the talk I would
normally with an in-person audience
point to someone that I
you sitting in the front row but
unfortunately I can't do this year sorry
and we have to use the same platforms
and tools right we have to have the same
common understanding so that everyone's
operating from the same share data and
understanding rather than blaming each
other and saying you are services broken
new your service is broken so things
like open telemetry which is a shared
standard can really help you get on the
same page with Inter operating and
instrumentation and make sure you reward
curiosity and teamwork practice blame us
post mortems and give people shout out
when they did something that helped you
out my team at work has a has a channel
called hashtag love where we express
gratitude to each other for things that
we did it's amazing it's a really
heartwarming place to be we also have to
learn from the past and reward ourselves
by doing those way most post mortems but
also by doing risk analysis because our
allies do not exactly repeat that they
rhyme and there are common design
patterns that we can use to mitigate our
most common sources of outages so we
need to your risk analysis we need to
plan why well if you're a bridge that's
having cars fall through the roadbed
because the road that has fallen into
disrepair and there might be an
earthquake in 30 years but it's a while
out so it needs a seismic retrofit and
he's a shiny new coat of paint and it
needs lights decorating it which of
these should I prioritize which one
should I do first I should fix the fact
that cars are falling through the deck
of the bridge and falling into the water
like so our systems why do we not treat
our systems the same way why are we not
prioritize what we work on with our
systems you so often see people kind of
doing random acts of chrome polishing
doing what seems shiny rather than
focusing on the impact first so we need
to quantify our risks by how often they
happen and how bad they're going to be
so frequency is something that we don't
have much control over but I think it's
important to be aware of right if you
have a my sequel database that underlies
your your your operations then you know
that my sequel database will fail in
some fashion in the next year you don't
know when you don't know how but it will
fail probably mean time between failures
in one year so the thing we do is
control over is impact how many people
will be in
and that my sequel database fails does
it have to be a critical failure or can
we degrade our service in some way so it
isn't a critical failure can we have an
only impact a smaller proportion of
users rather than impacting a hundred
percent users maybe we can shard things
or maybe we can have hot standbys so
that we failover more quickly so that
the impact lasts less time for instance
if we had a hot standby so we could be
all over within five or ten seconds
rather than having to rebuild the
database manually and have it take 30
minutes
well that shortens the impact with
outage order if we could detect the
outage sooner and take action before it
impacted 100% of users these are all
things that we do have control over so
multiply these risks out to understand
both what's most significant and also
what what are the changes that would
move the needle the most right what do I
have the most control over that would
decrease the greatest amount of risk and
when thinking about this we need to keep
our service level objective in mind and
our service level objective says that
we're allowed to have a thousand bad
requests per month and something is
contributing five hundred bad requests
month that is probably a single source
of failure that we need to address
really really fast because that's
imperiling our ability to deliver a
service objective and it doesn't leave
enough room for unknown unknowns of
course there will be unknown unknowns
that you can't predict that's the nature
of the game but if our known and knowns
are taking up so much of our error
budget that we have no room left for the
unknown unknowns well that's kind of the
first starting place and also critical
path latency matters right it doesn't
make sense to optimize to prematurely
optimize something that's off your
critical path if you're trying to
achieve a hundred millisecond SLO or 100
millisecond service although indicator
um then don't fix the thing that's
seeking one millisecond take that big
thing that's taking 30 milliseconds that
is a single blocking point before you do
your fan-out so your service level
objective can really help you make the
business case to fix them because you've
agreed over you with your business this
is the level reliability or between
target this is the level of performance
or training target so something is
imperiling you're a delayed to do that
then you know we can fix it and we
should devote time to fixing it and
actually prioritize completing that work
that doesn't mean write down everything
from
retrospective or post-mortem and do all
of them just find the two or three most
important things and make sure those get
done promptly so don't waste your time
doing chrome polishing or side projects
like experimentation is okay but like as
a as a comprehensive reliability
practice random acts of reliability do
not actually achieve systems reliability
and resilience but here are two risks
that you may not have thought of
first of all a lack of observability is
systemic risk if you cannot see into
your systems if you can't understand
your systems you're wandering around in
the dark without a flashlight and
without a headlamp it's going to take
you much much longer to understand and
fix every single outage and while it may
not show up as a single item on your
shirt if it increases every single other
item on your risk chart by a thirty
minutes or hours or days of duration of
impact that adds up that really really
adds up so really prioritize being able
to see into your systems secondly a lack
of collaboration kills teams and kills
products if you do not feel safe
collaborating with other people if your
team points fingers you're not going to
raise an issue and say I think customers
are impacted you're not going to say I
think it was my change that broke the
build or that that broke this is that
broke this user let's roll it back right
if you feel that they're going to get
fired or blamed for pointing out is that
that they were the cause air quotes for
failure remember outages have triggers
and not and not root causes outages have
contributing factors so if we don't
emphasize collaboration or outages are
going to take much much longer than heck
can fix so make sure that you prior has
psychological safety in your
organization's you don't have to be a
hero in order to be successful you just
have to practice production excellence
you just have to inspire the right
things of culture and practice in your
teams I want to reflect for a moment
about the about the DevOps research
recent research metrics by the
accelerate state of by the accelerate
team
so elite teams deployed multiple times
per day they take less than a day to -
from the time that you did that you
write the code to the time that's
running in production it takes some less
than an hour to restore service and less
than 15% of their changes fail and for
many teams it's actually more like 0.1%
of changes so teams are doing this teams
have gotten there this is what it looks
like right like you have you have teams
now in 2019 their survey game if you
know that 20% of teams are able to do
this this is amazing right like it used
to be fewer than one person now it's 20%
of teams but still a majority of teams
are stuck in the low performance
category where it's taking them months
to roll out changes weeks to fix
problems where 50% machines are broken
and have to be rolled back and don't get
rolled forward for months right this is
a bad state and we really need you as a
DevOps community bring people into the
fold and help them get better to help
them progress what things do we know
predict this automated build automated
unit tests automatic to plan to
production and observability if you
can't observe your code then you have no
idea how it's performing in production
whether or not it's broken or whether
it's working correctly and who's
impacted so a dozen engineers are
responsible for building honeycomb I
counted we have nine engineers who range
code full-time and then we've got about
five of us who write code part-time
that's it and we build systems that make
we make systems that are humane to run
we made your systems for me to run
because our systems ingest inflammatory
let you explore your data and empower
your engineers and yes we deploy on
Fridays right and we don't deploy on
weekends because we own have breaking
changes over weekends so we'll to fly up
to Friday like 3 p.m. 4 p.m. our
criterion is can you stick around and
watch your change can you observe your
change in production before before you
go home for the day and similarly you
can see the gap here right like we
didn't deploy over Christmas
we didn't deploy we didn't deploy over
Christmas we didn't deploy over a
Thanksgiving right like
we have a humane practice but it took
work to get there how did we get there
well we started off with making sure
that we could deploy things quickly that
we're able to have our builds take less
than 10 minutes that we can push changes
out every single hour the shorter you
make your lead time the more often
you're able to deploy and that means
that your changes are isolated from each
other and you're only deploying one
thing at a time and that means that you
have increased confidence because you're
using observability to wash your code
both as you're developing it and as it
goes out to production we're able to
turn things off with a flag flip or fix
for it off and rather than having to
emergency rollback less than one in a
thousand changes catastrophic we fail
for us we've had in the past year over
2000 deployments and we've had fewer
than than two catastrophic failures that
could not be addressed via flag flip or
or just degradation in six board and
time to our store is really really low
for us because we've really invested in
the ability to both observe what's going
on and be able to control what's going
on flag let's take 30 seconds for us
rolling back to a previous bill takes
less than 10 minutes
fixing forward tech it takes only 20
minutes and this means that our service
is able to punch above its weight we're
able to accomplish so much more with
nine engineers than other teams that
have hundreds of Engineers can do so
high productivity product engineering
starts this lead time deploy frequency
chain i improving change fail reading
time to restore but all this is on a
bedrock of everyone being invested in
observability so by the right tools yes
but make sure that as you're getting
that alphabet soup seasoned it with
rocks next ones it'll make your team's
in your efforts so much better so
production excellence brings your claims
closer together when you measure what's
broken and measure when things are too
broken how are able to debug your
outages with observability have adequate
collaboration between your teams and
have a feedback loop and mechanism of
doing risk analysis for addressing your
second bullet thank you very much and if
you have questions for me um you can go
to sled oh I just a cultivating
production excellence talk and the code
at the bottom and I look forward to
seeing your questions thank you very
much and if you want my slides there at
honey Co / lids or honeycomb dot io /
lives barcode is in the upper left hand
corner